des républiques populaires de toniets et
ruggansk les habitants des eaux Blast 2
à Gier et de Kerson les députés de la
Douma et les sénateurs de la Fédération
de Russie
vous savez que dans les républiques
populaires de daniès Logan dans les
oblatsson ont eu lieu des référendum
et nous avons calculé les résultats et
nous connaissons le résultat de ces
référendums les gens ont fait leur choix
et ce choix est sans équivoque
aujourd'hui nous signons les accords
d'adhésion de ces territoires à la
Russie
je suis convaincue
l'assemblée fédéral va soutenir la
création de 4 nouveaux régions au sein
de la Russie ce sera les quatre sujets
administratifs nouveaux de la Fédération
de Russie c'est la volonté des millions
des personnes
bien sûr c'est leur droit
fondamental qui est écrit
dans notre loi fondamentale et dans la
dans les statues de l'ONU
[Musique]
du droit de l'autodermination des
peuples
nos ancêtres encore dans l'ancienne
Russie
ont défendu la Russie c'est sur cette
territoire romaine
ou chaque enfant combattue
sont connus et ici nous avons eu des
victoires lors de la Grande Guerre
rapatriotique en 2000 14 certaines
personnes n'ont pas accepté le coup
d'État fasciste en Ukraine il y a des
gens qui sont morts pour pouvoir
défendre le droit de parler leur langue
leur foi leur droit de vivre ce sont des
martyrs de dessin de casting ce sont des
victimes des actes terroristes organisés
par le régime de Kiabi ce sont engager
volontaire ce sont des civils ce sont
des femmes enfants et hommes se sont des
personnes de nationalité
ukrainiennes et russes c'est le leader
populaire zakarchenko de deniers
monsieur Pablo Vevo
c'est le procuré de la République de
Lugano c'est le combattant gâtiment
et toutes les autres personnes qui ont
perdu leur vie lors de cette opération
militaire spéciale ce sont nos héros
ce sont les héros de la grande de la
Grande Russie et je demande une minute
de silence en leur mémoire
merci
du choix des millions des habitants des
territoires de Johnny
mais derrière ce cache notre Histoire
militaire c'est un millénaire pardon
c'est un lien parmi les générations et
ces gens ont l'amour pour la Russie et
personne ne peut détruire ce sentiment à
l'intérieur de nos âmes c'est pour ça
que les différentes générations les
anciens et les jeunes
pour notre unité pour notre avenir en
commun
en 1991 à Bello BG on a signé en accord
on n'a pas demandé
l'accord du peuple c'est les
représentants des élites de du parti de
l'époque qui ont pris cette décision en
ne pensant pas alors patrie et
ça crée des divisions
parmi notre peuple c'est transformé en
catastrophe nationale comme après la
révolution on a créé des Républiques et
on a tracé les frontières de manière
artificielle ainsi à l'ordre du
référendum
1991 on a détruit démantelé notre grande
partie patrie et
on se retrouvait devant le fait accompli
je pense que les personnes qui sont
derrière ça comprenaient ce qu'elle
faisait notamment les Américains mais
maintenant c'est trop tard d'en parler
c'est de passer l'Union soviétique
n'existe pas et la Russie n'en a plus
besoin d'ailleurs ce n'est pas notre
objectif
des peuples c'est peuples qui pensent
qu'ils font partie de la Russie par leur
langue par leur appartenance par leur
histoire leurs ancêtres pendant des
siècles ont vécu dans un état uni ils
sont déterminés à retourner dans leur
patrie historique
entend
longues années pendant 8 ans ces gens
étaient sous les bombes et les tirs et
en kersonnes
essayez d'inciter à la haine contre
tout le monde contre
russe
à l'Occident je voudrais que tout le
monde le retienne les personnes qui
vivent dans les territoires de donetskor
Luans
pour toujours
à cesser la guerre qu'il avait commencé
en 2014 et à retourner derrière une
table de négociation nous sommes prêts à
cette discussion nous l'avons déjà dit
mais les peuples de ces quatre
territoires ont fait leur choix on va
pas revenir sur ce choix et la Russie ne
va pas les trahir
et si vous devenez
d'aujourd'hui doivent respecter ce choix
libre des personnes et pas autrement
c'est la seule voie qui mène à la paix
et nous allons défendre notre territoire
par tous les moyens qui sont dans notre
disposition nous ferons tout pour
assurer la sécurité de
notre peuple c'est notre mission de
libération nous allons reconstruire les
villes et les villages les écoles et les
musées nous allons développer les
entreprises industrielles les
infrastructures les systèmes de retraite
le système social de la santé de
d'éducation nous allons augmenter le
niveau de sécurité et ces personnes qui
habitent dans les nouvelles régions vont
sentir le soutien de tout le peuple
russe de toutes les régions
toutes les villes de la Russie
je voudrais aussi m'adresser aux soldats
et aux officiers qui en font
combattre lors de l'opération militaire
spécial
de la mobilisation partielle il y en a
d'autres qui ont rejoint les rangs de
l'armée je voudrais m'adresser aussi à
tous ces nouveaux appelés alors famille
à leur femme et enfants je voudrais leur
dire pourquoi combattre notre peuple qui
est notre ennemi et qui pousse le monde
dans cette nouvelle crise équipe a
intérêt à continuer cette guerre
mon frère et soeurs en Ukraine qui font
partie de notre peuple ont vu par leur
propre yeux ce que prépare les
dirigeants des dirigeants
occidentaux pour tous ces peuples les
masques sont tombés
qui n'accepteront jamais de vivre sous
l'hégémonie de quelqu'un d'autre et
l'Occident fait tout pour instaurer un
système
néocolonial pour continuer à payer les
autres peuples
entier
c'est une orante d'hégémonie que
l'Occident veut instaurer et garder
c'est ça l'autre véritable volonté et
c'est pour ça qu'il cherche
à contrer
les processus
centrifuge des mouvements séparatistes
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas cette
intégration ils veulent que les peuples
se libèrent de leur souverain et en fait
qu'il se donne aux États-Unis et
certains pays acceptent cela de manière
volontaire et il s'accepte de devenir
des vassaux des États-Unis d'autres sont
achetés et si il n'arrive pas à le faire
ils peuvent détruire des pays entiers en
créant des catastrophes humanitaires des
ruines des millions des vies humaines
détruites des enclaves terroristes des
protectorats des colonies de semi-coloni
mais il ne s'arrêtent devant rien pour
atteindre leurs objectifs étirés leurs
profit
à cause de cette volonté
à cause de Laura avarice que les
Occidentaux continuent cette guerre
contre la Russie il voudrait qu'on soit
leur colonie
mais il ne s'agit pas d'une coopération
d'égale à et il voudrait nous piller on
voudrait qu'on soit leurs esclaves ils
n'aiment pas notre pensée et notre
philosophie c'est pour ça qu'ils
attaquent nos philosophes parce que
toute notre culture est en danger et un
risque pour eux et notre développement
et notre bien-être c'est un problème
pour eux ils n'ont pas besoin de la
Russie mais nous nous en avons besoin
je voudrais vous rappeler
de l'hégémonie mondiale ce sont heurtés
déjà à la volonté de notre peuple et au
courage de notre peuple l'Occident
espère que cela allait passer et dans le
passé effectivement
il y a eu
exemple de cela et donc on jette
on continue à élargir l'OTAN vers l'est
et les
promesses qu'on a faites aux dirigeants
soviétiques sont oubliés et ont déchire
les contrats et les accords
internationaux on continue à entendre
que l'Occident protège l'ordre qui fixe
sur des règles mais ce qu'elle règle et
qui a défini ses règles et qui a accepté
ses règles c'est vraiment désine et on
voit depuis longtemps c'est double
standard qui
prennent tout le monde pour des
imbéciles la Russie est en grand pays et
ne va jamais suivre ces fausses règles
aux frontières
et il pense que
certains peuvent le faire et d'autres ne
peuvent pas le faire pourquoi
peuvent-ils prendre des décisions qui
leur a donné le droit de décider c'est
eux-mêmes
sont tellement
énervé et en colère contre le droit
de la primée qui a fait son choix
à travers le monde entier et c'est du
racisme il s'agit du racisme également
quand on attend on entend parler de la
culture néolibéral qui devrait être
l'idéal pour le monde entier et de dire
si vous vous êtes pas vous n'êtes pas
avec nous vous êtes contre nous
[Musique]
ils ont commis le crime historiques mais
il essaye toujours de trouver d'autres
coupables il voudrait que d'autres pays
et d'autres peuples demandent pardon par
exemple si on parle des conquête
coloniale il faudrait rappeler aux
Occidentaux que c'est encore au
Moyen-Âge que les Occidentaux ont
commencé cette politique ensuite elle y
a eu un e-commerce des esclaves ils ont
payé l'Inde l'Afrique il y a eu des
guerres de l'Angleterre et la France
contre la Chine et la Chine a été
obligée d'ouvert ses d'ouvrir ses ports
pour le commerce d'opium et
qui ont été poussés à consommer de la
drogue des ethnies entières ont été
éliminées il y a eu une chasse aux
sorcières parmi les peuples entiers
siècle c'est notre pays qui a été à la
tête du mouvement anti colonial pour
lutter contre les inégalités dans le
monde contre la couvre-tout
donc les élites occidentales sont aux
rues sont forts elles sont en colère
justement
contre nous parce que nous avons résisté
à créer un monde de commerce équitable
grâce à l'état très fort que nous avons
pu créer nous avons passé notre état sur
des valeurs fondamentales et des valeurs
chrétiennes
islamique bouddhiste et autres
plans d'intervention en Russie
après 1917 notamment et avant cela on
n'a jamais pu envahir la Russie mais
l'Occident a pu quand même attendre les
richesses de la Russie à la fin du 20e
siècle on nous a appelé ami ou
partenaire
comme une colonie et des trillions des
dollars ont été piliers de notre Russie
nous nous en souvenons nous n'avons rien
oublié et
que de la région de Kerson et de
zapperons
voté pour la réunification de notre
territoire merci
occidentaux
parle toujours du fait qu'ils apportent
la liberté la démocratie mais c'est tout
à fait faux c'est le contraire c'est au
contraire l'exploitation au lieu de la
liberté c'est
l'esclavage et tout cet ordre mondial
est antidémocratique et anti libéral
tout cela est une hypocrisie
sont le seul pays qui a par deux fois
utilisé l'arme nucléaire dans l'histoire
en anéantissant Hiroshima
avec les Anglais ont transformé en
ruines sans nécessité
militaire ont anéanti les villes de
hampoule de Brest en Allemagne sans
nécessiter militaire c'était une manière
démonstrative et
la même chose qui est arrivé avec ce
bombardement nucléaire il s'agissait
d'intimider le monde entier les
États-Unis ont laissé un très grand feu
souvenir dans les peuples de Corée du
Japon l'emploi au Vietnam tu n'as pas
mais de l'arme chimique
l'Allemagne le Japon la République de
Corée
sont considérés comme des
égalité quel type de d'égalité est-ce
que
représente en fait ce sont des
dirigeants qui sont aux ordres ou alors
même qui sont soumises écoute non
seulement dans leur bureau mais aussi
dans leur habitation personnelle et le
monde entier
et en fait les vassaux
ça va être
les Européens vont être la l'objet de la
solidarité
Atlantique cette politique destructrice
de gens vers la migration des milliers
de gens qui vont chercher à rejoindre
l'Europe vont périr
et voilà ce blé qui vit de l'Ukraine et
qui va sortir du Crès pour assurer
le
maintien en vie de population
affamée en fait ce blé il va en Europe
au détriment mon pays qui en ont besoin
ces deux
tromperie
et en fait les Américains utilisent
les tragés
la France l'Espagne l'Italie Washington
et exige sanctions toujours renouvelées
contre la Russie la majorité des
responsables sont obéissants ils
comprennent bien que quand les
États-Unis imposent à lieu de renoncer
aux ressources industrielles
énergétiques russes et bien cela
contraint l'Europe a anéanti sa propre
industrie et les Européens comprennent
tout cela les préfèrent servir les
intérêts des autres ça n'est pas le fait
de l'accueil c'est aussi des traîtres
vis-à-vis de leur peuple mais c'est leur
affaire mais les Anglo-Saxons ne sont
pas contents de il se lance dans le
sabotin ils ont
compris à des infrastructures
internationales qui traversent le fond
de la mer Baltique c'est une
infrastructure internationale nous
savons à qui le crime profite le chef
des États-Unis c'est le diktat de la
violence de la force
cela peut être enveloppé d'une manière
plus séduisante mais c'est un droit
fondé sur la violence et c'est ce qui
les amena déployés des centaines de
bases militaires de femmes
d'alliances militaire
c'est aussi
ceux qui s'opposent
comme des ennemis et c'est sur ce
principe que ce fonde la doctrine
militaire des États-Unis et de
l'otanique
Occident sont présentés d'une manière
entièrement hypocrite ça fait que une
prétention à la l'amitié pour la
et en fait
ce sont les mêmes éléments que l'on
retrouve dans les stratégies successives
il s'agit de
mettre fin et de faire capoter toute
tentative de
souveraineté et d'autonomie souveraine
ça touche
les pays de l'Afrique mais même les
partenaires et alliés des États-Unis dès
que quelque chose ne leur plaît pas et
bien les abeilles
prononcer des sanctions contre une
banque contre une entreprise c'est une
pratique qui va se développer ils sont
en une demi tous y compris notre premier
voisin les pays de la Syrie
en fait ils se prennent leur désir pour
des réaliser et c'est principe de
sanctions contre la Russie
il pensait qu'ils allaient réussir à
mettre en couple régler tout le monde
mais en fait ces sanctions sont
de nature
provoquer des réactions
sauf chez les masochistes la majorité
des pays refusent d'accepter cela ils
veulent maintenir une coopération
rationnelle avec la Russie c'est une
réaction que l'Occident n'attendait pas
en fait ils ont l'habitude de réfléchir
d'une manière
une pensée qui est restée
[Musique]
depuis le passé et il maintient leur
situation d'exception et en fait il y a
une véritable famille d'informations la
vérité a été
sevelit sous un
montage de mensonges et de propagande et
plus le mensonge est gros et puis il
passe mais on ne peut pas
nourrir des gens avec des millions de
dollars qui ont été produits par la
planche
en fait on ne peut pas chauffer le les
habitations des gens avec des de la
monnaie
qui n'a aucune valeur en fait on ne peut
et nourrir des gens avec du papier il
faut
alimenter les gens avec de la nourriture
et ses capitalisations gonflées elles ne
vont rien
permettre de résoudre il faut des
produits énergétiques donc
ne pas se chauffer de réduire le ratio
alimentaire
déclare extrémiste ennemis tous ceux qui
disent contre qui se disent contre cela
et on affiche la Russie comme la source
de toutes les malheurs
en fait on peut très bien comprendre que
les élites occidentales n'ont pas
l'intention de rechercher une sortie de
la crise alimentaire qui est devenu de
leur fête de leur faites et bien avant
notre opération militaire spécial en
Ukraine
[Musique]
je n'ai pas l'intention de résoudre tous
les problèmes d'inégalités
je pense qu'ils sont prêts à utiliser
tous ces recettes dont ils ont
l'habitude
l'Occident au commencement du 20e siècle
à connu la Première Guerre mondiale la
deuxième guerre mondiale a permis aux
États-Unis de surmonter la Grande
Dépression cela leur a permis de devenir
le pays qui a avec le dollar la réserve
la monnaie de réserve du monde entier
en partie
détériorer mais l'Occident a pu sauver
sa situation grâce à l'effondrement de
l'Union soviétique
tous les pays qui ont cherché la voix
d'une souveraineté autonome se trouve en
buste
ces actions on peut penser que
le système entier voit s'effondrer ou
imploser
et en fait une guerre ça permet de tirer
un trait sur le bilan
isme d'aujourd'hui
et de rester maître de cette pillage de
marché
et cela permettra de priver des
milliards d'hommes amis de l'humanité du
droit à déterminer leur propre avenir
des fondements
essentiels de la moralité du droit de la
famille et là je voudrais revenir à ce
que je voudrais parler à tous les
citoyens pas seulement les collègues qui
se trouvent dans cette à tous les
situations
en Russie au lieu d'un papa on avait
le Christ dans le discours
ces hommes aux fruits qui le portent et
c'est ce que nous voyons
le monde est entré dans une période de
transformation révolutionnaire il y a de
nouveaux centres développement qui
représente la majorité de la communauté
mondiale et ce n'est pas seulement les
intérêts que l'on peut
un monde multipolaire dans lequel ils
vont pouvoir défendre leur autonomie et
donc leur véritable liberté et leur
liberté
un développement autonome créatif dans
le monde entier y compris aux États-Unis
et en Europe nous avons beaucoup de gens
qui qui partage notre pensée nous
sentons le soutien de ces
Jean-Claude nous sentons qu'il y a un
mouvement colonialiste qui se développe
dans le monde entier contre cette
hégémonie
et c'est cette force qui va déterminer
l'avenir de la géopolitique aujourd'hui
nous luttons
la liberté pour nous-mêmes pour la
Russie
despotisme et au dicton qui sont des
éléments passés et la notion
d'une supériorité
de naissance d'une
certaine classe de l'humanité il faut
tourner cette page de l'histoire et
c'est où
possible le monde ne reviendra pas à la
page d'avant
l'époque
mener cette
lutte cette bataille pour notre pays et
pour notre tête c'est la bataille pour
la Russie
de belles choses
historique pour nos enfants et nos
petits enfants nous devons les défendre
contre ces expérimentations monstrueuses
qui
tendent
esprit faire en sorte que notre histoire
notre culture soit éradiquée
nous devons
solidariser nous devons nous fonder sur
la Solidarité sur la créativité et la
justice je voudrais terminer
si je considère que mon pays c'est la
Russie
spirituelle tu peux plus son esprit
c'est le mien son destin c'est mon
destin
mon malheur
son épanouissement
ce sont des principes qui après plus de
millénaires nous amènent devant
et ce choix a été fait par les peuples
des républiques populaires de lugaris et
les habitants des 30 ans de personnes
être victorieux avec la Russie
nous sommes
un et la Russie et derrière vous